[Applause]
[Music]
boy is he playing well now 15 points in
each three of six
I mean that's just got skilled offensive
player right there and he can keep Jimmy
Butler from getting shots over the top
White
[Music]
at the top we said my Alpha versus your
Alpha Jason Tatum right now putting on a
show
[Music]
hands off to Robinson sheds white a
floater on the Fly will not go and a
Hartford rebound
[Music]
s higher for two all with great defense
well Tatum is doing it at both in
there's again at that length and that's
the difference in the game right now
they're guarding each other so there's a
lot of switching but he's gone right at
Jimmy Butler Jayden has scored the last
10. shot right there it out of bounds it
goes and look at over top here on the
back side Tatum with the block no
breathing space huh
to convert Vincent Butler Tatum right
there and stolen again a turnover for
Miami
Dwight met by three out to Tatum goes
and takes him Robert Williams going into
the back
Butler got a screen finds again
he thought he got all ball down goes by
Luna whistle
another strong decisive move Reggie no
hesitation here going off one foot no
pump fake it's a tough call I don't know
because of his ability to shoot the
basketball
well they needed that
inside Tatum and he had room to do it
you don't necessarily need it to read
but it will go a long way
Tatum
[Applause]
Butler will defend Tatum shot pocket
Ford
[Applause]